[Music]
good morning everyone my name is Karla
Merritt and I am currently a junior
pursuing a degree in chemical
engineering I will be your mistress of
ceremonies during this morning
celebration
welcome to the 26th annual dr. Martin
Luther King jr. celebration I would
first like to take this opportunity to
thank President Charles Vess and his
wife Rebecca VES for hosting this event
I would also like to welcome dr. Shirley
Ann Jackson president of Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute MIT class of 1968
in 1973 it is a it is a pleasure to have
you here this morning
furthermore I would like to thank all
the members of the dr. Martin Luther
King jr. planning committee to whom we
owe this wonderful event when I call
your names please stand so that you can
be recognized
professor Jerome Friedman professor
Richard Milner professor Wesley Harris
assistant professor Melissa Nobles
assistant professor Larry Anderson
associate dean Arnold Henderson junior
[Applause]
assistant dean and David Shaw
Ronald Critchlow
Reverend Jane Ghul event Lane
[Applause]
Trudy Morris
Paul para Bono
Robert sales
toby whiner
associate provost Phillip clay special
assistant to the president dr. Clarence
G Williams Hugh Ann Thomas
Felix a young
and co-chairs Dean Leo Osgood jr. and
professor Michael filled
in addition we would like to express our
appreciation to the students who were
here early this morning to help with the
preparations for this event
thank you all for contributing to the
success of this morning's event we will
now have a selection from the MIT gospel
choir lift every voice and sing by James
Weldon Johnson we ask that you join in
and sing the first verse please stand
and join hands as a song is sung
[Music]
[Applause]
as my job till victory is won
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You MIT gospel choir for that
outstanding rendition of lift every
voice and sing we will now begin the
program with the invocation delivered by
Reverend Jane s school following the
invocation breakfast will begin after
breakfast we will have two students
Ibrahim Fontaine class of 2003 and Tamra
Williams a graduate student they will
give lead us in a reflection on the life
and legacy of dr. Martin Luther King jr.
then we will hear remarks from President
Charles in vests and he will have the
distinct pleasure of introducing our
keynote speaker dr. Shirley Ann Jackson
Chancellor Lawrence s back out will
present the 1999-2000 Martin Luther King
jr. Leadership Awards following that
presentation Provost Robert a brown will
recognize the 1999-2000 Martin Luther
King jr. visiting professors now let us
begin our program with the invocation by
reverend jane ghoul right after reverend
ghouls invocation we will begin
breakfast o mortal what is good and what
does the Lord require of you but to do
justice and to love kindness and to walk
humbly with your God as the prophet
Micah asked the people of Israel in the
eighth century before the Christian era
so must we ask ourselves at the dawn of
the 21st century we gather this morning
to reflect on leadership bold leadership
connective leadership transformative
leadership last Friday I accompanied my
son's fifth grade class on a field trip
to the Kennedy Museum as I watched the
videotape of Martin Luther King Junior's
I have a dream speech and read the
documents of the civil rights era I
realized that I was the age of my son
when I heard King preach in the Nash
Cathedral on the last Sunday of his life
concretely and graphically I understood
that a generation has passed and King's
dream remains unfulfilled in his 1963
letter from the Birmingham jail King
wrote let us all hope that the dark
clouds of racial prejudice will soon
pass away and the deep fog of
misunderstanding will be lifted from our
fear drenched communities and in some
not too distant tomorrow the radiant
stars of love and brotherhood will shine
over our great nation with all their
scintillating beauty dr. Shirley Ann
Jackson stands before us today as
evidence of the progress made as well as
as a challenge to stay in the struggle
so that we might transform the face of
leadership for the new millennium yet
for all of us gathered here there is an
inherent risk in heating the words of
the prophet Micah and taking to heart
the commitments of dr. King King's
mentor the Reverend dr. Howard Thurman
wrote the reassurance of a secure income
the quiet glow of working with a safe
and respected institution in
conventional ways the sense of
well-being that comes from being
accepted by everyone because one's
thinking is sensible and safe all of
this makes for a certain kind of deep
tranquility but there is apt to be no
growing edge and very little of the Tang
and zest of aliveness that only the
adventurous spirit knows it is not an
accident that the messengers of the gods
were symbolized as human beings with
wings ages before we thought of the
possibility of flying through air
the god of life is an adventure and
those who would affirm their fraternity
must follow and so we give thanks this
morning for the food that strengthens
our bodies for the dazzling array of
bright minds that stimulate our thinking
and for the presence of committed
individuals who inspire our action that
we might be holy adventurers seeking
justice doing kindness and walking
humbly with our God amen good morning
everyone my name is Ibrahim Fontaine and
I'm a sophomore in the mechanical
engineering department when I heard this
year's thing for the annual Martin
Luther King jr. celebratory breakfast
engineering bold leadership for the 21st
century the first thoughts that came to
my mind were community initiative
tenacity and manhood these are all
qualities that I feel were possessed by
the man we are celebrating here today
immediately the question arises how will
we people of color display leadership
within our community in order to make a
positive change for the 21st century
being college students at a preeminent
university we are in a powerful position
to make a strong influence dr. King was
a bold leader I think this goes without
saying yet part of what made dr. King
such an exceptional leader was the
dynamics of the community that he served
these dynamics of the black community
have changed over the years yet there
has to be a sense of community in order
for us to understand the need that
currently exists otherwise the great
historical and cultural ties that has
connected us as a people will be lost
and a permanent separation will exist
within our community between those who
have and those who do not this brings me
to my second and third thoughts on this
on the theme for this year's breakfast
positive change does not occur without
effort
in order for us to show leadership in
the 21st century we must possess
tenacity and initiative one of the
greatest dangers I see within my
community is complacency we cannot
become satisfied with current situations
dr. King possessed both tenacity and
manhood his hunger and desire to end the
plight of black people and was inspired
not only by his personality but also by
his relationship with God we too must
possess this tenacity the greater the
level of spirituality that exists within
our community the greater initiative and
understanding for change will exist I
want to make my final point by
addressing a subset of our community the
quality that we as men of color must
possess his manhood today as men of
color we are still viewed by society as
public enemy number one
all too often society attempts to
emasculate us by directly associated our
face with crime in order for us to
become positive leaders in the 21st
century we must assert our manhood as
dr. King did during his nonviolent
protest for civil rights out of all the
words I have used I feel that this is
the most difficult to define or explain
however I have a few thoughts on what I
feel that exemplifies manhood means
changing the negative to the positive
manhood means fulfilling all
responsibilities manhood means
controlling your environment and not
letting your environment control you
manhood means defending and securing
resources in your community and finally
defining yourself and not letting
yourself be defined or dictated by
others these are the qualities we must
possess in order to engineer
leadership for the 21st century thank
you
[Applause]
Thank You Ibrahim for those inspiring
words now we will proceed with Tamra
Williams Tamra
[Applause]
good morning everyone
today I will speak to you on the subject
when shall we arrive death the point of
no return you cannot escape the fact
that death will someday come knocking on
your door many of you will have lived
life to the fullest having achieved your
spiritual professional and personal
goals yes some of us our lives will be
cut short snatched away without warning
such was the case with the men whom we
commemorate on this day dr. King stared
death in the eye each time he took a
public stand for the civil rights of
colored people I can imagine the 23rd
psalm resonating in dr. King's mind yea
though I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death I will fear no evil for
thou art with me on the night before dr.
King's death he stated with tears in his
eyes like anybody I'd like to live a
long life longevity has its place but
I'm not concerned with that now I just
want to do God's will dr. King refused
to stray from the path of equality and
justice for all and a society built on
total inclusion the year 2000 is upon us
and we have yet to answer dr. King's cry
for equality any given day we can pick
up a newspaper and read about a young
black or Hispanic man who has been
gunned down like an animal because the
police thought he had a gun
just the other week officer call cornell
young junior was shot by his colleagues
because they mistook him for a criminal
mr. young was not shot once but three
times in the head the chest and the
abdomen and time would fail for me to
mention the countless Native Americans
Africans African Americans
afro-caribbeans Asians Hispanics
Chicanos and Latinos who have been
beaten tortured maimed lynched and raped
because we appear to be a threat to the
social structure of this great country
country excuse me
furthermore technological lynching
continues to exist at our finest
universities administrators faculty and
staff continue to ignore the exclusion
of minorities which is just as dangerous
as placing a noose about our neck and
hanging us from a tree I don't know
about you I don't know about you and I
don't know about you but I don't need to
see another cut person of color gunned
down
beaten or dragged to their death for me
to realize that America has a need of
racial tolerance in President Clinton
State of the Union address he said we
should do more than just tolerate
diversity we should honor and celebrate
it this echoes the legacy of dr. King
who fought for equality
I want you to go away today thinking
about the fact that it has been less
than 50 years less than 50 years since
people of color have required
legislative civil rights as opposed to
rice obtained through those committed to
high ethical principles as a society
built for hundreds of years on the
premise of segregation discrimination
and racism is not capable of radical
change unless the powers that be insist
on correcting past wrongs until we can
bravely
face this fact dr. King's dream will
remain just that a dream a dream a dream
thank you
[Applause]
once again I would like to thank you
bro-heem Fontaine and Tamra Williams for
letting the words of dr. King be heard
once more thank you now I have the honor
of introducing the 15th president of MIT
dr. charles invest president vest will
give some remarks and proceed to
introduce our keynote speaker dr.
Shirley Ann Jackson
Thank You Carla and good morning before
I begin my remarks I'd like to take just
a moment to recognize two distinguished
representatives of the larger Cambridge
community who have joined us for this
morning's program representing the
Cambridge City Council I am pleased to
welcome our mayor ken Reeves Ken and
here today representing the city of
Cambridge as well as police commissioner
Ronnie Watson mr. commissioner
MIT is committed to working closely with
the city of Cambridge across the full
spectrum of Educational Development and
civic affairs we share a common
responsibility to fulfill dr. King's
vision of a strong mutually supportive
community we are pleased that you can
join us in rededicating ourselves to
that shared goal a few years ago Becky
and I were privileged to be invited to
dinner at the home of un
secretary-general Kofi Annan as you know
the Secretary General is an MIT alumnus
it was a glittering and for us very
memorable evening the dinner was held to
honor the outgoing president of the UN
General Assembly who and asked to make a
few informal remarks began by saying
something along the following lines the
General Assembly is a collection of
brilliant and talented people but what
do we do we dressed nicely in pinstripe
suits and talk politely and endlessly
about a number of matters and the
gracious and dignified manner most of us
become good friends and we certainly
have a lot of mutual respect but we
never talk about the real issues the
hard things that should be bluntly
confronted perhaps in academia and here
at MIT we are too guilty of something
along these lines we gather annually to
celebrate the legacy of dr. King and to
remind ourselves that although the path
is long and hard and the goals seemingly
distant we have much to be grateful for
and many triumphs and heroes to
recognize and thank most of all we
gather to express our pride in our
remarkable students with whom we work
and learn and lead I look forward each
year to this celebration and its sense
of vision and re commitment to the cause
of building a just society today however
I want to follow the diplomats advice
and talk about a really hard issue
one that many of us in this room know
and worry about but rarely talk openly
about one for which I certainly admit
upfront I don't have the answer the
issue is the gap between ability and
achievement of far too many minority
students in American colleges and
universities we in leading colleges and
universities have two fundamental duties
toward all of our students first to seek
and admit talented accomplished and
motivated young men and women and second
to provide a learning environment that
enables them to realize their highest
academic and personal potential last
year at this breakfast and in the
subsequent Boston Globe editorial I
discussed the misguided movement in this
country away from explicitly considering
race as a factor in admissions decisions
the core of my message and indeed mi
t--'s message was this we believe that
considering many factors in admissions
including race allows us to build a
class that promotes the best educational
experience for all of our students and
that it increases our ability to help
build a strong coherent and productive
Society for the future we must sustain
these principles we must continue to
publicly champion the critical
importance of diversity in college
admissions and campus life and learning
and we will the fact is that by applying
these principles we do get the right
students they represent an extraordinary
variety and mixture of backgrounds
African American Asian American is a
Caucasian Hispanic and Native American I
like to say to people that MIT students
come from the upper left hand corner now
what do I mean by that it goes like this
the faculty and staff who read
applications to MIT assigned to scores
ultimately to each applicant
one score is quantitative it's based on
grades SAT scores ranked in class
Advanced Placement performance and so
forth
the second score reflects
non-quantitative matters such as essays
initiative accomplishments and
leadership and activities beyond the
classroom community service
high level competitions and so forth
these two scores establish a matrix
those in the upper left-hand corner of
this matrix have done remarkably well in
both dimensions in other words they're
the cream of the crop MIT students come
from the upper left-hand corner of that
matrix our white students come from the
upper left-hand corner our minority
students come from the upper left-hand
corner they are the best the same is
true at other highly competitive
colleges and universities across the
country we get the right students but
today let us turn for a moment to the
next stage academic success of these
great students and our responsibility to
them here is an undisputed fact
undisputed but highly controversial
difficult to interpret and not discussed
it is clearly summarized in the book the
shape of the river by Bill Bowen and
Derrick block that book reports on their
study of the academic performance of all
students in 28 competitive colleges and
research universities across the country
this major study describes the great
successes of three decades of
affirmative action in higher education
but it also contains a most troubling
finding Bowen and Bach note that noted
that admission to and graduation from
kinds of selective schools included in
the study pays off handsomely for
individuals of all races and backgrounds
and in some sense even more importantly
it pays off handsomely to our nation
however the overall grades of students
of color in these schools statistically
lag behind those of other students even
when corrected for factors such as high
school grades SAT scores socioeconomic
status gender school selectivity and so
forth in this statistical analysis of
academic performance there's of course a
huge individual variation but the
underlying pattern is evident the
findings of the study clearly show that
far too many of our minority students
are not achieving their full academic
potential this at a time when we need
them to be the best as they prepare to
be our leaders in this new century of
American life now MIT was not one of the
universities included in this study but
we must examine this question in a
substantive manner on our campus as well
our leading colleges and universities
enroll enormous ly gifted minority
students and we need to understand the
reasons for the gap between ability and
achievement it is not helpful in my view
to immediately retreat to some
ideological or political position on any
side of this issue nor frankly do I
believe that we should just decide the
tests are racially biased and stop at
that we need to understand what's going
on and then we need to roll up our
sleeves and go to work on it after all
at MIT we're engineers and we like to
think that once we've identified a
problem we've taken the first step
toward finding the solution and the time
to attack tough issues is when we can do
so from strength and we have that
strength right now our strength derives
from the remarkable contributions made
by MIT minority students and graduates
during the last three or four decades to
science engineering politics business
community development and the our
our good colleague dr. clarence williams
chronicles many of the contributions of
these graduates in two forthcoming books
I have read much of these in draft form
and I can tell you that the achievements
of these men and women are truly
awe-inspiring and yet their reflections
on their MIT experiences also raise a
persistent question given the talent and
promise of our students and the
resources that we devote to developing
that talent have we done are we doing
our best as mi t--'s president I must
listen to learn from and act on the
constructive criticism that they and
many of you have raised with me and
that's what I'm attempting to do today
we need to work together to create and
sustain a learning environment that
brings out the best in all of our
students I can think of no better goal
for us as we enter the 21st century and
I think we must undertake this task with
optimism and confidence why am i
optimistic well just look around this
room
it's full of remarkable individuals you
just heard from two of them students
faculty staff administrators and guests
whose achievements and contributions to
society are extraordinary
I suspect that right here is the key to
enhancing our understanding let us begin
by learning what makes for success not
just thinking about problems let us
learn from each other's experiences
challenges and individual successes the
successful individual studied by dr.
Williams took personal responsibility
for their academic accomplishment and
they took direct advantage of the
opportunities afforded by MIT regardless
of obstacles they may have encountered
let us in addition take community as
well as individual responsibility for
the academic success
every one of our students there are
hints out there about concrete actions
that we can take let me cite just three
examples the first has to do with
mentoring one of the crown jewels of MIT
education is Europe our undergraduate
research Opportunity Program which is
celebrating today its 30th anniversary
it is a wonderful way for students to
get involved in real world-class
research and to find faculty mentor and
yet we know that proportionately fewer
minority students choose to sign up for
your op we need to understand why and
then correct it and we will Kim Vandiver
our dean for undergraduate research has
made this an important priority and I'm
confident that we can turn it around the
second example has to do with creating a
stronger learning community people at
MIT have always thrived on the intensity
of competition and individual
achievement yet as noted in the report
of our task force on student life and
learning these factors have also led to
an environment that is fragmented in
many ways we need to develop community
across cultures across our campus one
place where this happens is the
leadershape program now entering its
sixth year students from an
extraordinary array of ethnic and
cultural backgrounds spend an intensive
week together getting to know each other
and themselves talking about their
aspirations and developing projects to
make those dreams come true we need to
build on the lessons that we are
learning from this kind of experience
and make them available to all of our
students and finally there's the matter
of expectations we need a community that
not only gives members the opportunity
to succeed but that treats all of its
members with the assumption that they
can and will succeed
that begins right within each of us our
expectations of our students and of
ourselves must be high over and over on
the videotapes in the intuitively
obvious series we hear our students talk
about how hard it is to succeed when
your teachers or others send you signals
that they don't think you have what it
takes when they have lower expectations
of you than you have of yourselves the
committee on campus race relations is
now making an updated version of these
tapes let us learn from our students
it's all right there now I have put this
issue of expectations and academic
performance on the table so that we can
get to work on it over the last few
months I have talked with many of you
about our students and how their
environment for success can be improved
as a result of these discussions I want
to tell you that I am in the process of
putting together a task force to tackle
this head-on it will be results oriented
and it will have a specific timeline we
will formally announce the group in the
near future and once we do I will invite
all of you to send your ideas your
suggestions our way as I said at the
beginning the first step toward a
solution is identifying the problem and
asking the right questions I am
confident that this place if any place
can find the solution by building an MIT
that is not only inclusive but is
sustaining we can take a big step
forward toward creating a better
learning and living environment for all
of us such a community must be based on
equal opportunity to be sure and it must
continue to be one of supremely
ambitious talented and hardworking
individuals but it must also be one of
mutual respect of self-confidence of
shared purpose and of the highest
expectations we owe this to ourselves
we owe it to our students we owe it to
our nation we owe it to our society
let us not waver from our collective
responsibilities and let us never waver
from our resolute commitment to the
dream thank you very much
and thank you
and now it is my privilege now it is my
privilege to introduce our keynote
speaker from her student days to the
present moment we at MIT have been the
beneficiaries of dr. Shirley Jackson's
vision leadership tenacity remarkable
coalition building skills and her wise
observations and advice always delivered
with her characteristic candor after
graduating from MIT with her doctorate
in physics in 1973 she pursued her
research interests at nuclear
accelerators in this country and abroad
before joining Bell Labs in 1976 Oh
Shirley I said labs instead of
laboratories inside joke in 1991 she
became professor of physics at Rutgers
University while continuing as
distinguished research physicist at Bell
Labs in 1995 President Clinton appointed
her chair of the US Nuclear Regulatory
Commission this was a great gain for our
nation and a loss for MIT because she
had to take a leave of absence from our
corporation our board of trustees while
she held that high government position
last July as we all know dr. Jackson's
career took another turn as she assumed
the presidency of the Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute but we have her
back as a lifetime trustee of MIT now as
I said at her inauguration I've noticed
that these days many university
presidents have taken to calling
themselves CEOs now Shirley Jackson is
no CEO
although believe me she certainly could
be one if that's what she chose she is a
university president in the profound
sense of that title that is to say she
understands at a deep level the essence
of universities the importance of the
life of the mind the goals and
aspirations of students
and staff and the unique role that the
Academy plays in our society and she
will lead accordingly as she already has
on our campuses and on the world stage
now it is my very great pleasure to
present my colleague and dear friend dr.
Shirley Ann Jackson
[Applause]
thank you Thank You Chuck very much and
good morning today we are celebrating
one of the greatest men to ever live the
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr. dr.
King had a tremendous influence on my
life I was a high school student when he
delivered his famous I have a dream
speech and he was assassinated in my
senior year at MIT which had a lot to do
with my decision to remain at MIT as a
graduate student and I think an
influence on what has happened to my
life
since then we all know that his dreams
and ideals transcend race and time and
his I have a dream speech is one of the
great speeches in American history while
opportunities for african-americans have
improved since the untimely death of dr.
King we by no means have attained his
vision of a better world prejudice and
racism are still thriving in our society
and education is the best way to kill
them in the past few years we've seen an
african-american man dragged to his
death because of his color dismembered
dismembering his body a gay man beaten
tied to a fence post and left for dead
because of his sexual preference
government workers killed by a man who
hated the government and decided to blow
up their place of work and a man so
threatened by technology that he sent
mail bombs to individuals he felt were
furthering its development these types
of heinous crimes drive the imperative
during our celebration of dr. King's
life to rededicate ourselves to working
toward his vision for America for the
world
when I spoke to you some of you at this
celebration in 1986 I never could have
guessed the road that I would be
traveling in the ensuing years while
working at AT&T Bell Laboratories I
became involved with issues of science
technology economy and public policy and
served a number of terms on a variety of
state commissions in New Jersey then in
1994 I was approached by the Clinton
White House about serving as a member
and the chairman of the United States
Nuclear Regulatory Commission and as you
know I served in that capacity from mid
1995 until this past July when I began
my tenure as president of Rensselaer
Polytechnic Institute or RPI being the
chairman of the NRC as the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission is called was
truly an honor and an awesome
responsibility in that role I oversaw
the development of policies to ensure
the protection of the public health and
safety the common defense and security
and the environment in the peaceful uses
of nuclear energy and nuclear materials
in the United States I also had the
responsibility to ensure that the NRC
staff carried out these policies in
accordance with statutory requirements
as you might imagine I interacted daily
with government officials scientists and
engineers from around the world as well
as with the White House the Congress and
public policymakers in Washington DC one
of the most enjoyable parts of my job
was representing the government of the
United States at various international
bilateral and multilateral meetings and
commissions knowing that the policies
that I helped develop influenced
international nuclear safety and nuclear
non-proliferation was headed yet
sobering
despite the gravity of my position I
have to tell you I could not help
smiling from time to time as I traveled
internationally because I realized that
dr. King would have been proud that the
face representing the United States at
major nuclear meetings and summits
around the world was black and female
his activism and leadership surely made
a difference yet there is still much to
be done others have given testimony to
that this morning when I last spoke to
you in 1986 MIT enrolled approximately
300 african-american students last year
MIT enrolled 348 African American
students in 1986 there were 14 African
American faculty members today there are
25 while these numbers are improvements
they are not enough but MIT is not alone
I could tell you were statistics about
the institution i'li minority
representation in science and
engineering is embarrassingly low across
the country this issue has been
discussed continuously for 15 years but
little has actually changed and there's
evidence at least with respect to
african-american males that the
situation is worsening a particularly
troubling statistic concerns the numbers
of African American students who are
completing four or more years of college
according to the US Census Bureau in
1985 only 59 point eight percent of
black students completed high school in
1997 that number had jumped to 74 point
nine percent graduate
despite this marked increase the number
of students going on to complete four
years of college only increased 2% from
11.1% to 13.3% this situation is a
larger problem than merely increasing
the number of african-american students
enrolled in engineering and science
fields we all must work to increase the
number of african-american students
especially african-american males
attending and graduating from
institutions of higher education
interestingly enough whether our
students like it or not although I'm
sure the students here recognize it
serving as role models is important for
each of them and one often overlooked
because of the influence of the media
our young people often look toward role
models and heroes from pop culture and
athletics while there are worthy
individuals among these ranks they
cannot be the only possible candidates
to which our youth look we need young
people to see role models of color in
corporate America in academia and in
government which means that we must push
our current minority students to help
accomplish this we as leaders must
explain to our students the important
role they play in diversifying all
sectors of our society and the impact
that fact will have on the next
generation that means imposing demanding
standards of excellence and achievement
even as we strive to create more
community in the higher education
institutions in which they study we need
high achieving minority especially
African American Hispanic and Native
American
scientists and engineers professors
corporate leaders entrepreneurs and
government officials to expand the
vision of our young people of what they
too can accomplish because of the
progress that has been made since the
1960s we have more role models in the
professional ranks than ever before
women for example are finally moving
into the highest ranks of corporate
America including the first CEO of a
Dowell 30 company Carly Fiorina of
Hewlett Packard and women have led the
successes of newer companies that have
become household names meg whitman has
built ebay into an overnight success
story and joy Covey is currently the
chief strategist between a behind
amazon.com in fact two of the three
largest US banks have female finance
chiefs Dina Dublin of Chase Manhattan
and Heidi Miller at Citigroup
african-americans also are finally
appearing in boardrooms and at the
executive level in corporate America and
in government franklin raines
is the former director of the Office of
Management and Budget and currently is
the CEO of fannie mae in Silicon Valley
John Thompson is president and CEO of
software manufacturer
semmen tech the current United States
Secretary of Labor is Alexis Herman and
the Secretary of Transportation is
Rodney Slater and I could cite a few
more
and while these and other successes are
an improvement we have a long way to go
before the corporate executive ranks and
high-level public policy positions are
representative of the face of America
for that matter the road to travel to
executive leadership in academia also is
long although progress is being made
while women presidents of higher
education institutions may not be
commonplace across the country
especially when one looks at
african-american females they are
actually in the capital district in the
Albany region in fact four of my
colleagues at neighboring colleges and
universities are women at Skidmore
College the sage colleges Empire State
College and SUNY at Albany
however our numbers are few according to
the 1999 Chronicle of Higher Education
Almanac the most recent data from 1995
showed only 16 and a half percent of
college presidents were females it also
stated that approximately 10% of the
presidents belonged to a minority and
5.9 percent were African American
actually the diversity among faculty
ranks is even worse
only 3.2 percent of all full-time
professorships are held by African
Americans the number is five thousand
two hundred and forty out of one hundred
and sixty three thousand six hundred and
thirty-two I always say you have to look
at the numerator and the denominator
now this fact is not just appalling it
is unacceptable leaders in higher
education then must take a bold approach
toward effecting the change needed to
correct this situation Americans look to
institutions of higher education for
leadership in a variety of areas
including the production of future
leaders to be effective then we in
leadership positions must look
introspectively at our own leadership
qualities and abilities and at our own
institutions
are we living the gospel we preach are
we talking about the changes that need
to be made and are we rolling up our
sleeves and effecting those changes are
we developing programs to promote
diversity while also working to
diversify our own workforce are we
looking at our current structures and
programs to see if they can meet the
needs of the student body we want to
attract and retain we need to ask
ourselves these questions and more we
cannot expect more of our students than
we ask of ourselves the American system
of higher education is lauded around the
world partly because of its independent
nature each school within broad
statutory regulatory or accreditation
guidelines is autonomous to create its
own policies curriculum and standards
this model gives us a great advantage to
adapt to the needs of the country
however as leaders we must be willing to
take on the challenge of doing so change
does not come very easily especially
especially in academia the traditions of
the ivory tower are very strong but as
dr. Robert Jarvik you know who he was he
was one of the first designers of
artificial hearts and he said the
following leaders are visionaries with a
poorly developed sense of fear
and no concept of the odds against them
they make the impossible happen at
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute I have
begun a process the development of the
Rensselaer plan now this plan will be a
blueprint for the future identifying the
direction in which we need to travel to
achieve a position of prominence in the
21st century as a world-class
technological research university with
global reach and global impact the
Rensselaer plan will take shape from 3
informing principles excellence
leadership and community the process is
still under way but it has been
enlightening and enliven for all of
involved students faculty staff and
alumni have all made contributions
during the public comment period we
posted it on the web that just ended the
next draft is being completed and will
undergo another review I plan to present
the final plan to our trustees in May
two core tenants of the Rensselaer plan
our diversity and community or community
as I like to call it to be competitive
in the 21st century our University's RPI
must reflect the society we hope to
serve and lead and we must develop
multicultural awareness among our
students recognizing this fact I have
insisted that diversity be a major
tenant of our plan
you know technological advances have
made our world smaller than ever things
we consider passe and almost obsolete
today the calculator tape players and TV
dinners were great advances 20 years ago
now our students have the ability to
instantly communicate with someone
sitting at a computer on the other side
of the world most of us have
concentrated our efforts towards giving
our students the technological tools
they will need to be competitive in the
computer age however we have often
overlooked the importance in their
future success of their ability to deal
with change and diversity having a
diverse student body is one way to
assist our students in this area
diversity at Rensselaer and in the
Rensselaer context has four elements
geographic diversity intellectual
diversity gender diversity and ethnic
diversity tolerance and Communiversity
will make it all work Communiversity
refers to the university as a community
as a family it also is meant to describe
the fact that the university is part of
the city the town indeed the larger
Society of which it is a part members
then of the community can and should
should work to ensure the viability and
vibrancy of their shared community
traditionally institutions of higher
education have used their admissions
policies to ensure the diversity of
their student bodies during the past few
years however affirmative action and the
college admissions process have been
under intense scrutiny and attack the
usefulness and fairness of affirmative
action practices have been
debated both publicly and behind closed
doors we must read the same thing in
their book the shape of the river
william bowen and derek bought block
took a systematic look at race-based
admissions policies and affirmative
action at a carefully chosen group of
selective admissions colleges and
universities and at the subsequent
successes of their alumni in their
summary they concluded and I quote
substantial additional benefits accrue
to society at large through the
leadership and civic participation of
the graduates and through the broad
contributions that the schools
themselves make to the goals of a
Democratic Society in other words higher
education administrators and public
policy decision makers must recognize
the importance of minority graduates and
the importance that they play in the
larger American society now let me talk
specifically about science technology
and engineering because much attention
has been paid to issues of
underrepresented minorities and women in
these arenas unfortunately as I said
earlier all the discussions have done
little to change reality to make any
real difference I believe we truly have
to try a more holistic approach we
cannot merely focus on the students who
are getting ready to apply to college we
must look at the system in which they
are being educated currently many of us
in universities are seeking out those
underrepresented students whom we
believe can succeed but we also must
begin to create opportunities at an
earlier stage for those students who may
not recognize their potential for
success this pipeline needs to be fully
developed and supported by the
university's local communities
industries
and school districts a full pipeline
depends upon key points of intervention
along the way these interventions must
address the achievement gap of African
Americans and other underrepresented
minorities when compared by conventional
measures with their white and Asian
counterparts yes I'm talking about
testing results and sometimes actual
achievement in college now before all of
you fall out of your seats let me say
that while I do not believe that SATs or
any test scores give the full measure of
the individual and while I certainly
agree with William Bowen and Derek Bok
about the societal benefits of
successful graduates of selective
institutions MIT and Rensselaer among
them I also know that the achievement
gap is a nagging concern that threatens
to undermine the continued and needed
expanded opportunities for
underrepresented minorities in these
institutions it also threatens to
undermine the confidence of these very
same students that means we must look at
the institution's themselves and we must
look at the pipe through which they come
competitive institutions have cultures
that tend to view excellence and caring
as an oxymoron but this isn't so if we
admit the best students we cannot
squander the talent
if we admit the best students we cannot
squander the talent we must have an
equal commitment as universities to
their academic and life success my son
is a freshman in college he's a freshman
at Dartmouth and I know that the four
years between high school and college
graduation are key years in the
development of a successful adult and in
their view of their alma mater
once they've graduated an expectation of
excellence and a nurturing of that
excellence go hand in hand
this is the standard at Rensselaer
especially with our undergraduates but
the standard cannot disappear as it
often does when we go beyond majority
and/or male students this is the
challenge we face to walk that talk with
all of our students universities
especially highly selective ones must
take a more activist role in pre-college
education let me tell you about an
example at Rensselaer about which I am
very excited it's called Project Ray's
the Rensselaer alliance to increase
student excellence more than 900
low-income students from the local area
will receive advanced instruction in
algebra chemistry physics and
trigonometry beginning in the seventh
grade and continuing through high school
this ambitious effort also will involve
mentoring and financial planning for the
students and their parents while this
activity only recently got underway
it recognizes that preparation to enter
scientific and technological careers is
a cumulative process one cannot aspire
to be a scientist an engineer and
entrepreneur or technological leader
without a grounding in calculus but one
cannot do calculus if one cannot add
subtract multiply and divide and if one
cannot do geometry trigonometry and
algebra but the learning also depends
upon incentives to the students and the
understanding of their parents project
raised tries to build these factors into
the program higher education also must
take a more active role in the
professional development and continuing
education of outstanding primary and
secondary school science and math
teachers it's interesting because when
we're in the university almost any
administrator will tell you that the
core the key to the excellence of the
university aside from the students it
attracts and what allows them to attract
those students is the faculty but when
we look into the pre-college arena
we sometimes seem to lose sight of that
fact but who better to identify future
successful students than their teachers
and who is in a better role to interest
students in the opportunities in
mathematics based and scientific fields
than these teachers so universities in
corporate America need to develop
sustaining partnerships and programs to
make teaching attractive to talented
individuals in mathematics science and
engineering who are actually trained in
these fields to expose these teachers to
the latest innovations and research
currently being conducted the fields
that I'm talking about are changing so
rapidly
that we cannot expect teachers educated
even five and certainly ten years ago to
have any grasp of the current
innovations and cutting-edge
technologies teachers need the
opportunities to work as part of their
contracts on a continuing multi-year
basis as partners in innovation and as
researchers alongside colleagues in the
industries and in the universities and I
intend to do this at Rensselaer teachers
can then take their professional
experiences back to the classroom and
share them with their students and I'm
not talking about the one-time summer
program I'm talking about an actual
career path we're working in the
university of working in the local
industries is an actual part of that
teachers those teachers contracts the
enthusiasm and the excitement the
teachers develop through their own
relevant experiences will translate into
more vibrant and exciting classes for
their students because excitement is
contagious and I have no doubt that it
will influence some students who may
never before have considered a career in
science mathematics or engineering we
also must take a look at how at how we
are preparing our current College
student body to become successful alumni
are we preparing them only to be
successful scientists and engineers or
are we also preparing them to be
informed and participatory members of
our society and these issues go hand in
hand and when I was a student I was
admonished too many times about doing
something other than my studies but how
we prepare our students to succeed in an
increasingly complex and global economy
it's gonna be hard to do if they have no
idea how to deal with the real diversity
and complexity of the global workforce
indeed if they do not value it and
embrace it higher education must then
offer students the opportunity to
explore the entire universe around them
not just the universe of their fields of
study a concomitant challenge is to make
Communiversity a daily reality this
means not only fostering community
within the campus but to provide
opportunity beyond the campus perhaps as
part of the structured curriculum for
our students to collaborate with the
larger community to improve the quality
of life experience that redounds to the
benefit of all this can be local that
can be at remote locations or even
through virtual interactions and we're
experimenting with these ideas and their
combination at Rensselaer now I remember
how easy it is and as I say I was
admonished anyway to get caught up in
one studies you know I was very serious
about my work and that always came first
the pressure on students to be
successful is very large yet I also
remember that some of the greatest
lessons of life I learned while
attending MIT did not happen on the
campus they happened when I was
volunteering in the pediatric ward at
Boston City Hospital or tutoring at the
Roxbury wine or planning an event for my
sorority Delta Sigma Theta and those
lessons the lessons of humanity and
humility of organization of realizing
that another struggles can be greater
than one's own helped me to become a
better human being and consequently
have contributed to the successes that I
have achieved research institutions like
MIT and RPI have an added duty to
fulfill these needs because of the
professional successes of our alumni we
should not only be creating leaders in
engineering and science we need to be
creating role models for others to
emulate Paul D Shafer said quite aptly
the most important single influence in
the life of a person is another person
who is worthy of emulation as
administrators we have to keep this fact
in mind at all times we must create
opportunities for our students to be
engaged in realms beyond their studies
and in realms that enrich their studies
and to help them develop into confident
high achieving well-rounded mature role
models for the next generation of
students finally let me speak to
leadership on a personal level I firmly
believe that we who are in leadership
positions must set personal examples of
commitment hard work adherence to high
ethical standards and the courage to
take on the status quo in how we shape
our own institutions and in how we speak
to the larger society taking on these
challenges is not easy but they must
happen in what manner of man dr. King
wrote the function of Education
is to teach one to think intensively and
to think critically intelligence plus
character that is the goal of true
education those were dr. King's words by
creating an atmosphere in which our
students can be and must be academically
challenged with an expectation of
excellence while learning to embrace and
celebrate diversity to explore broader
cultural and intellectual interests to
become confident we can positively
influence an entire generation of
Americans that is the goal to which we
all must aspire and to which we dedicate
ourselves as leaders and as role models
I like to paraphrase a in a different
way a quote from a famous movie and it
simply is leadership is as leadership
does then and only then will we be
creating the world of which dr. King
dreamed thank you very much
now I have the honor of introducing
Chancellor Lawrence s back augh
Chancellor back out will present the
1999-2000 Martin Luther King jr.
Leadership Awards Chancellor back oh
thank you very much Carla it is a
distinct honor and pleasure to have the
opportunity today to present these
awards today we gather to celebrate the
life of a true American Hero and I can
think of no better way to do so than to
recognize and honor those among us who
best exemplify his principles his ideals
and his dreams indeed the student
faculty and alumni that we recognized
today are in many ways heroes in their
own right they have shown us each the
path the path to the dream and I think
in doing so if I may also represent a a
concept which is Inbal embodied in the
ancient Hebrew texts the Talmud which
speaks to the obligation of tikkun olam
the obligation for each and every
citizen to try and repair the world and
I think each of the three people that we
recognize today
in their own way has done so I'd like to
call upon our first awardee to come up
professor Rafael bras
in his letter of nomination mr jor-el
Rivera president of the Society of
Hispanic Professional Engineers cited
your inspirational and steadfast
commitment to underrepresented students
at MIT during the past twenty four years
Rafael your achievements at the
Institute as student faculty member
department head program director and
advisor have motivated and encouraged
countless young people from all
backgrounds while ceaselessly
contributing to the field of hydrology
and hydro climatology you have never
lost sight of those who wish to follow
in your footsteps
whether serving as director of the mites
program or successfully recruiting
Hispanic faculty to MIT you have
embodied dr. King's vision by generously
and selflessly working to provide better
opportunities for those who have been
denied as mr. Rivera app aptly stated
you are always encouraging minorities to
achieve their best Rafael is one of our
great scientists at MIT a wonderful
teacher a terrific department head and
outstanding colleague and I have to also
add a distinguished member of the class
of 1970 to my class
Rafael congratulations
[Applause]
thank you very much Larry
indeed the class of 72 is unique there's
a tradition in my family every year the
weekend of Martin Luther King Day we go
skiing in New Hampshire it is always a
wonderful time share with our closest
friends driving back in the evening that
Monday we always listen and I hope
you'll do to Eric in the evening which
is a jazz program in public radio in the
last few years
host Eric Jackson entertain us by
skillfully alternating music with the
species of dr. Martin Luther King it is
truly amazing how it went full of 15
year old boys falls silent at the cabins
of dr. King's incomparable style I wish
I only wish I had that power of oratory
if anything I could keep the children
quiet in one of the speeches played this
year dr. King hammered on the advice of
an older woman and it went something
like this
when in doubt when you have self-doubt
when things are not going right always
have faith God will help
I like to say that the more recent
version of that if anybody will seen the
movie fields of dreams build that they
will come life is full of challenges to
that faith I see the nation playing
political football with a six-year-old
well it turns back at the same time 400
desperate Haitians including men women
and children
I think we most all of us have faith
that ultimately rationality will prevail
as dr. ves stated and dr. Jackson also
alluded to I see affirmative action
being dismantled
I must have faith that men and women of
goodwill will stop the inevitable damage
that we see already sometimes more often
than I would like
I see lack of civility on acceptable
behavior among us
I wonder word is my leaders but again I
must have faced that reason we'll keep
us focused on our mission
and sometimes yes I catch myself being
unkind to others I find myself being
caught in the current
trying to rationalize what I really know
things that are not correct
I find myself forgetting the important
things in life at that point though
faith is not enough I know that is
really up to me and only me to make it
right
maybe that is what faith is all about
hoping that all individuals flawed as
all as we are all take responsibility
correct our mistakes deal with our
problems and act with honesty let me end
by simply thanking you for honoring me
I'm really humble Thank You MIT thank
you the committee for my selection and
thank you for the Society of
Professional Hispanic engineers for
denomination thank you very much
thank you very much Raphael I do not
like to call upon our next awardee dr.
Woodrow will Whitlow to come up
[Applause]
dr. Whitlow has the distinction of
having three degrees from MIT our
program only notes one but in fact there
are three all from from course sixteen
he is currently the director of research
and technology of the Glenn Research
Center of the National Aeronautics and
Space Administration in Cleveland Ohio
having spent the earlier part of his his
career at NASA headquarters in Langley
Virginia in his letter of nomination of
dr. Whitlow professor Wesley Harris
cited is invaluable commitment to
furthering our nation's Science and
Technology goals by developing unique
research programs that create
partnerships between NASA centers u.s.
industry and historically black colleges
and universities as a scientist director
graduate thesis advisor profession a
professor at majority institutions and
at Hampton University your endeavors and
distinguished accomplishments are
consistent with dr. King's ideals the
members of the Martin Luther King
committee strongly believe that your
efforts are a fitting tribute to his
vision and a full inclusion for every
person in our society and that they will
make this a land where all talent is
nurtured and valued in addition to being
an extraordinary leader in his own right
a distinguished alumnus of MIT I'm also
pleased to note that dr. Whitlow is a
fellow member almost of the class of 70
to 74 and a fellow Detroiter Woodie
congratulations
[Applause]
no thank you
I remember back in the the early 60s
going to downtown Detroit with my mother
and father they took me to March with
dr. King back in the days when he was
telling us about his dream for an
America that included the contributions
of everybody with the opportunity that I
had to come to MIT I had a chance to
realize my dream almost of becoming an
astronaut because I thought that the way
you did that was you came to MIT and you
majored in aeronautics and Astronautics
and then you went on to NASA and then
you became an astronaut it was a very
simple process never gets slightly
detour but I've never ever doubted my
decision
after leaving MIT the things that I
picked up here and particularly
recognizing that one of the major
reasons that I had the opportunity to
pursue that dream was due to the efforts
of our keynote speaker dr. Shirley
Jackson who at the time we said was only
a graduate student but strike more fear
into the hearts of us than any professor
ever could
so I would again like to thank Shirley
Jackson
for her efforts on the cause on behalf
of of our students in fact most students
has come sensor and the contributions
that she's making to society I've always
thought that it was required to give
something back to help as many people as
I could if that only included one that
would be appropriate I would like to
think that I've been able to pursue and
help realize dr. King's dreams with the
efforts that I've made at the Glenn
Research Center we have four key values
quality openness integrity and diversity
diversity been to value the
contributions of everyone an inclusion
of everyone and that includes not just
African Americans or Hispanics or Asians
but also those of non minority
population I would like to thank the
nomination committee the selection
committee like to thank dr. Wes Harris
who I don't think was able to be here
today most people don't know that I was
West's first PhD student it's been a big
influence in my life a big friend in my
life and continue to value his
friendship I would also like to dedicate
this award to my mother and especially
to my father who missed send me receive
this award by about two months so I
would like to dedicate this award in his
memory thank you very much
Thank You dr. Whitlow our next recipient
is tecora Jones decora please come up it
is often said thank you it has often
said that if you have a busy job - a
difficult job to do give it to a busy
person and in looking over to Cora's
resume I am astounded she has managed to
accomplish great things and to do many
things during her her time here at MIT a
member of the class of 2000 she is
majoring in material sciences in
engineering she has found time to work
at the IBM Research Center to be a
teaching assistant in organic chemistry
to do to work in the MIT second summer
program she's managed to travel to
Sweden to work at the Royal Institute of
Technology
she has assisted Dean Osgood and others
in the office of minority education I
could go on our students MIT is a great
place largely because we get great
students in tecora is a wonderful
example I would like to read from the
the letter which Decorah received in
which she was named a Martin Luther King
Leadership Award recipient in his letter
of doctrine of nomination dr. Douglas
Matson of the department of material
sciences in engineering cited you as an
exceptionally resourceful in natural
leader who has demonstrated considerable
strength as a contributor to MIT your
ability to motivate others enable the
group of talented individuals to develop
and successfully complete a project with
multiple interrelated tasks the efforts
of your classmates resulted not only in
an outstanding product but also in a
deeper appreciation for what can be
accomplished by a skillfully directed
team the sign of a true leader a
commitment to achieving the best is
evident in your war
his vice-chair of the undergraduate
Association Finance Board and his
co-founder the black woman's Alliance at
MIT as the office of minority education
tutor of the year you have distinguished
yourself as one who is dedicated to the
highest academic standards the members
of the Martin Luther King committee
believed that you have embraced the
essence of what dr. King demanded of
himself and others and your endeavors
are a tribute to his dream to Cora
congratulations
thank you good morning as I look back
and reflect on what the life and legacy
of dr. Martin Luther King jr. has meant
to me I must say that I am very thankful
to be alive and a student in these times
that have advancement and technology and
to be a black woman engineer and what
seems as as the world is my oyster the
words to whom much is given much is
required come to mind as I thought of
how to express my appreciation for this
moment dr. King was given the challenge
of leading a civil rights movement that
changed the shape of what America is
pushing it towards what it could be
though our challenges as students may
not be as arduous we still must rise
above the expectations and help those
around us to meet their goals in this
new millennium at times things are hard
but I must take the time to say thank
you to my parents for the examples of
excellence their love and support that
has guided me along this path of life to
my grandparents whose hard work and
dedication has given me the spirit to
persevere
it's my extended family for their open
arms and hearts and to my MIT family
administrators mentors professors
friends and my BWA sisters whose hard
whose hard work advice love smiles and
just brighten so many days finally I
would like to extend my thanks to the
MLK committee for this wonderful moment
to all of you for coming out bright and
early this morning and I will cherish
this moment always finally to my fellow
students too much is given much is
required let us lead by example indeed
into this new millennium the world is
ours thank you
let me just before I turn it back to
Carla close by saying that while both
dr. Jackson and dr. vest have both
observed that the dream is not yet
realized I think based upon the three
awardees that we have recognized today
we can see that our future is very
bright thank you all thank you very much
and congratulations to all the award
recipients and now it's my pleasure to
introduce Provost Robert a Braun Provost
Braun will recognize the 1999-2000
Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors Thank You Carla as Shirley
reminded us this morning is dr. King
challenged us in many ways and one of
his most important challenges was to
celebrate cultural diversity it's my
pleasure this morning to tell you about
our continuing commitment to this effort
on the MIT campus and one of the crown
jewels of this effort is the MLK
visiting professor program that was
begun in 1995 its objective is to bring
to MIT outstanding scholars to
participate in teaching and research in
to enrich our community appointments to
the MLK visiting professor program are
made upon recommendations from academic
departments and come from all parts of
MIT this year we have eight MLK visiting
professors with us I'd like to take the
opportunity to recognize two individuals
who were with us this morning
the first is Miss Karen lacy karen is a
visiting lecturer in the Department of
urban studies and planning a doctoral
candidate in the Department of Sociology
at Harvard University she has research
interests in the suburban Savannah's
ation of middle-class blacks in the
United States at MIT she's teaching two
courses in the Housing and Community
Economic Development Group within dust
now
Aaron was with us sitting next to me at
the early part of the breakfast she had
to leave to participate in the honorable
profession of teaching a nine o'clock
class the second member of the MLK
program with us this morning is
Professor Arthur Mutambara a professor
Mutambara has a PhD from Oxford
University in his visiting the
Department of aeronautics and
Astronautics at MIT he's currently on
the faculty the mechanical engineering
department at Family FAFSA College of
Engineering in Tallahassee Florida his
research is very interdisciplinary it
can be characterized as a combination of
mechatronics and robotics and at MIT s
interacting with groups across several
laboratories and centers including the
Space Systems laboratory in the
information and control engineering
group within the aero-astro department
and Lidz the laboratory for information
decision systems his research covers
programs at the fusion multi sensor
fusion working with distributed
satellite system satellite orientations
robotics and mechatronics as part of his
educational contributions at MIT
professor Mutambara will give a series
of lectures in a course being co-taught
between aero-astro and mechanical
engineering professor muhammara will you
stand up please welcome
our other 6 MLK visiting professors
could not be with us this morning
they're listed in the green program one
of the things that I think is most
exciting this year is the fact that they
cover such a multidisciplinary mix we
have people that have been with us in
performing arts urban studies and
engineer in the number of different
disciplines and engineering really has
enriched MIT greatly for all of my
faculty colleagues in the audience
please take this to heart and nominate
more people for next year we can never
have enough of visitors thank you
we will now continue with some
announcements that are relevant to our
celebration I would like to announce
that the Martin Luther King jr.
committee presents the student
dedication to dr. Martin Luther King jr.
there is an installation design at 12:00
noon in Lobby 10 titled the struggle
continues this installation was
completed by a group of students / IEP
the consecration ministries will perform
at 4:30 in Lobby 7 followed by the South
Central Mass Choir performing at 5:00
p.m.
also in Lobby 7 in addition on Saturday
February 5th from 9 a.m. to 3 p.m. the
annual Martin Luther King jr. MIT Center
for reflective practice Youth Conference
presents community justice environmental
economic social and political
empowerment this event will be held at
the MIT Stratton Student Center on the
third floor for more information please
contact marui Kolbert at two five three
three two one six or you can email her
at M Kolbert at MIT edu now I'd like to
ask Reverend jangle to come forward to
give the benediction to close this
morning's program as a community we seek
individual and institutional
transformation dr. Shirley Jackson
professor Rafael bras dr. Woodruff
Whitlow tecora Jones Ibrahim Fontaine
tomorrow Williams and Carla Merritt
witness to the possibility of bold
connective and transformative leadership
for MIT the nation and the world
retired Archbishop of Capetown South
Africa and chair of the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission Desmond Tutu
once prayed Lord where I am wrong make
me willing to change where I am right
make me easier to live with may we take
the words of tutu to heart as we go
forth from this
to do justice to love kindness and to
walk humbly with our God amen
[Applause]
I hope that everyone has enjoyed this
morning's program it has been a
wonderful event which I'm sure we'll all
remember for a long time thank you for
coming and I hope to see you at next
year's breakfast this concludes our 26th
annual dr. Martin Luther King jr.
celebration goodbye
[Applause]